se finalmente sono libero niente più
linee niente esami niente schemi niente
più volte mi sembra di volare non è
possibile era un sogno
questo 3 0 0 non ci sono riscontri oggi
studio basta e rimandare a torino questo
gattino d'oro ma ho un po fame mi sai la
merenda ha mai visto che bella giornata
andiamo a farci nefasti settina insieme
ma come settimana l'esame e io non so
nulla devo studiare ancora tutte le
materie
non sono capace fra i misteri ed
elaborato fa schifo il presidente di
commissione sono sicuramente costoso
inutile è inutile studiare canto non
sono una mamma mi bacia nomadi boric mi
faccio venire l'ansia per gli amatori
abbiamo di parete studio comunque poi la
fattura secondo me quest'anno sarà
proprio oggi la perché comunque ci sono
inteneriti dal fatto come un passato un
anno di merda al massimo usati poi un
piantino ronde lisci un po e poi
comunque a me posto 60 un 60 non si nega
a nessuno
ora
se ti pare che fianco per un altro
studio io lo studio più tanto sono
preparatissima ho studiato 12 ore al
giorno tutto l'anno nonostante la dowd
che dici poco e in più il massimo dei
tre viti ovviamente punto al 100 non
vedo l'ora di dimostrare a tutti quanto
sono brava e studiosa comunque
prendetemi per pazzo ma quest'anno c'è
la dovevano togliere la maturità c'è io
non lo trovo corretto abbiamo passato un
anno di merda siamo stati malissimo non
abbiamo visto il compagno abbiamo
vissuto le emozioni adolescenziali
dell'anno della maturità e ci fanno fare
l'esame
io lo trovo giusto potevano almeno
toglierci qualcosa cioè per dire a cosa
servono le equazioni già cosa mi servono
le quali nel mondo reale perché ai
pittori e arte c'è un paese va tutto
online a chieti dipinge più vediamo
quali sono
sono solo le tre di notte e il orario
perfetto per iniziare a studiare quanto
mi piace a studiare di notte non vola
una mosca
c'è un clima così silenzioso così
pacifico nessuno che mi disturba mamma
che non mi chiama nice messaggio nessuna
distrazione
ciao ragazze facciamo questo audio per
salutarvi ci tenevo tanto a salutarli
prima di chiudermi defitivamente in casa
come sapete non ho fatto il tubo tutto
l'anno ed è giusto bolzano non passo
l'esame
ecco quindi vi chiedo gentilmente di non
coinvolgerli se uscite sono state alba
sabato due passi in centro perché io non
posso venire questo non è un addio non
arrivederci